من سيعبر بتركيا الى مئويتها الثانيه ففي
وجدان الاتراك تمت رمزيه لمئويه تاسيس
الجمهوريه العداله والتنميه المتربع على
راس السلطه منذ اكثر من عشرين عاما ام
تحالف الامه حيث الطاوله السداسيه الجامعه
لاحزاب يفرقها اكثر مما يجمعها ولعل
الجامعه الوحيده لها فقط الرغبه في اسقاط
العداله والتنميه وشخص رجب طيب اردوغان
وحده الشعب التركي من لديه القول الفصل
تاخذ الانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه هذه
المره طابع استفتاء على النظام الرئاسي
وكذلك على حكم اردوغان ومن خلفه حزب
العداله والتنميه الذي يواجه للمره الاولى
معارضه موحده بعد عقدين من توليه السلطه
لم يكن طموح اردوغان في البقاء على راس
السلطه خمس سنوات اخرى مهددا كما هو الان
يذهب الناخبون الى صناديق الاقتراع
وكواهلهم مثقله باعباء معيشيه في ظل
ارتفاع الاسعار وتدهور قيمه الليره وبلوغ
التضخم مستويات قياسيه معمق الفوارق
الطبقيه داخل المجتمع التركي اكثر من 60%
من الاتراك يرون ان الاقتصاد والبطاله
همهم الاول تنتخب تركيا رئيسها بعد اقل من
ثلاثه اشهر من زلزال السادس من فبراير
الذي قتل اكثر من 45
وادى الى النزوح اكثر من مليوني انسان في
ولايات في تركيا التي تصنف معظمها معاقله
لاردوغان وحزبه العداله والتنميه سيعطي
الناخبون اصواتهم لمن يرون انه الاقدر على
اداره تداعيات الزلزال وحمايتهم من كوارث
مستقبليه اللاجئون السوريون نحو ثلاثه
ملايين ونصف مليون سوري في تركيا بالنسبه
الى المعارضه فان هؤلاء ورقه سياسيه رابحه
فاعادتهم من حيث اتوا قد يعبدوا لها
الطريق للظفر بكرسي الرئاسه التحول
الديموغرافي في تركيا بعد اخر يحدد اي
المترشحين اقرب الى القصر الابيض فهذه
الانتخابات تشهد صعود جيل جديد ولد في ظل
حكم العداله والتنميه ولا يعرف غيره
ولربما يطمح جزء منه في التغيير قد لا
ينظر الاتراك كثيرا الى خارج حدود بلادهم
اذ يحددونه رئيسيهم المقبل غير ان سياسه
الدول وصورتها اقليميا ودوليا ماده دسمه
في المنافسه على السلطه فمثلا لا يمكن
تجاهل الحضور المؤثر لانقره في حرب روسيا
على اوكرانيا وانجاز الدبلوماسيه التركيه
للصفقه الوحيده بين كييف وموسكو خلال عام
من الحرب هو اتفاق تصدير الحبوب لتركيا
حضورها اقتصاديا وعسكريا في جوارها وكذلك
في القوقاز وشمال افريقيا والخليج وفي
القرن الافريقي باعاده علاقاتها مع محيطها
العربي والاقليمي بما فيه ايران واسرائيل
تعود انقره لنهجها صفر مشاكل تركيا عضو
مهم داخل النيتو لكن لديها خلافات مع
اليونان والدول الاوروبيه والولايات
المتحده في وقت تحافظ على علاقات متميزه
مع روسيا انه التوازن بين التناقضات الذي
تصوغ انقر عليه سياستها الخارجيه وهو ما
يعطي نتائج الانتخابات زخما اكبر